euh je vais reprendre les pompiers la
dent dans pas longtemps mais tu as
raison c'est bien qu'on en parle c'est
pour ça qu'il appelle également que
sectes avoir été je pense que l'armoire
faudrait que tu regrettes quoi ça va
quoi bon je sais que de tailler quoi
c'est toi vraiment faisable voiture pas
du boulot quoi tu joues tu nous regardes
et johnatan balles évidemment
merci mon chéri tu as le soir tu habites
ou alors j'habite en normandie dans la
basse normandie dans la manche
ouais dans la ba oui je connais tu viens
tu connais bien où exactement où
exactement vers l'est dans l'eau au
salon je connais très bien je connais
bien de l'histoire
il ya une très belle médiathèque à saint
lô qui embrassera d'ailleurs bénédicte
de l'accueil c'est pourquoi ces panneaux
d'accord mon bébé est ce que tu as envie
de repartir avec cette voiture
ben évidemment si la voiture de miracle
et ben voilà et ben oui est ce que tu
vas aller voir les tuche deux fois mais
ça c'est la caution non mais l'étude de
allez le voir sous le lit c'est un
carton voilà 2010 et ccc le bonheur
alors on va essayer de tous rentrer dans
la voiture si on arrive à tous rentrer
dans la voiture en moins d'une minute
en moins d'une minute les chéris après
on fera le parcours on monte dans la
voiture on doit tout faire mais après on
fera le parcours pour l'instant doit
monter en moins d'une minute tu gagnes
la voiture d'accord possible voilà les y
monte monte attendait nos cheveux
attendez je vais fermer va vous rester
comme ça c'est bon séjour malaisie
portez tous voulaient confirmer
on est à 4 5 6 à 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 et 10 11
12 et 13 en voiture
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce ballet de voitures par nature j'ai 13
ans qui remercie t'as pas l'air comme un
fou de plongée à présent